[Music]  brockton with the short pop nedo  is from brazil member of the  senior men's brazilian national team  worked his way into the starting lineup  pretty back-door  pass field with the bucket and he drew  the foul  nice little two-man game right there  westbrook  watching the defense as he's dribbling  caesar's teammate go back door he lays  it out in front perfectly  field with the catch and finish two  hands nice job  westbrook loved it  [Applause]  so beale and westbrook with 18 apiece  we did not see this beat just under six  to go  third quarter you know more of len plays  about  20 to 22 minutes a night and  you see the three-pointer go down there  for for beal  he's been left in right now because he's  playing well in seoul is bradley beal  [Applause]